[Music]
strange as it sounds accountants in
russia live dangerously
article 160 of the russian criminal code
embezzlement
i worked in real estate management fraud
is endemic you find it in nearly every
company in the industry
usually the boss shoulders
responsibility for that but here in
russia it's usually the person who
brings the prosecution that wins that's
what my boss did he filed charges
against me my guilt was quickly proven
the investigators said to me you won't
walk free your case fills 19 files and
it's a year-long investigation
the state prosecutor was looking for a
three-year sentence in the end i got two
first i was on remand
was worse than being in prison i was in
a small cell with 40 other prisoners
they were always there i had no privacy
then when i went to prison i lost all
hope i had no more dreams i just waited
for it all to end
[Music]
it was awful awful being ripped out of
your familiar surroundings and put into
strange new surroundings it was a world
that wasn't exactly pleasant
they took my family away from me even
though it was only me that was convicted
in the end
my whole family suffered
[Music]
visits were only allowed every four or
five months i didn't know how i would
survive the separation without the
chance to hug and kiss my loved ones
[Music]
i remember the prison as a dark hole
where nothing happens
when i arrived i was confused and
disoriented
then i got angry
angry at a system that steals years from
good innocent people
i only know this because i've spent time
in prison myself
[Music]
you